focus protection
the idea the policy what is focus
protection right so those i was saying
that there's two scientific bases right
so one is this the steep age gradient
the second is the existence of locked in
arms again i think there's not very
little disagreement in the scientific
community of both of those facts
if you put those facts together
the obvious policy is to protect the
people who are at the most severe risk
from the disease itself
and that's the idea of focus protection
that's the general principle of it
the actual implementation of it depends
on the living circumstances of the
people that are at risk
the resources that are available in the
community uh the
uh the technology is available to do
this
and so it's almost always going to be in
fact it'll always be a local thing
because it'll depend on the the the all
of those those things which are all
local in nature right so one
very very obvious thing in
a country like ours where so many older
people live in institutionalized
settings in nursing home settings
and that's where older really vulnerable
chronically ill patients often live
it is and you know this disease affects
that group most like most most commonly
it is absolutely vital to protect that
group
we should have known that in february
2020 from just from the chinese data
and we should have thought about that
group as the as this as the key
constraint
in our policy making
instead we thought about in february
march 2020 as hospital beds as the key
constraint
hospital beds and ventilator shortages
and that we so we we ran around trying
to like address that
constraint you know like a linear
programming problem you figure out what
the which constraints binding and you
address that one thing and then you go
on to the next one right
if that's it's that one constraint we
said okay the constraint is hospital
beds
that led to the decision in many of the
northeast states to send covet infected
patients who were on on the verge of or
like it looked like they were about to
recover back to nursing homes
who then spread the disease all through
there because they wanted to preserve
the hospital beds
well for somebody who loves the miracle
optimization i love the way you frame
this uh
but those are kind of connected right if
you actually focus on protecting the
vulnerable you will also
have the effect of
not hitting the ceiling of the available
that is that's the irony if we protected
the vulnerable the vulnerable the most
likely to be hospitalized and so by
protecting the hospital about protecting
the vulnerable we would also
have addressed the shortage of hospital
that's more effectively so that little
shift in priority would have had a big
impact
okay but specifically the idea is to
and we could talk about different ideas
of how to actually do this but uh you
know you
basically do a lockdown or something
like that on a very small set i mean you
may have to do that if it's community
spread is very high but generally i
think
it would depend on again the living
circumstances and the uh so so for
instance um
if you are in a if you have a uh here's
a very simple idea that doesn't require
a lockdown
forced on them i don't actually
generally are not in favor of that kind
of force lockdown because you just won't
get cooperation right um but what you
could do is provide resources to
that group of people so like ima imagine
you live next door to somebody uh an
older couple
um and it's there's high community
spread
well they have to go grocery shopping
um we did like some of these some
communities did these like senior only
grocery hour
right but but they have to still have to
go out and they might get exposed in
when they're shopping amongst other
seniors yeah
well why not organized home delivery of
groceries to them we did that for the
laptop class
right uh or or we can even just as a
volunteer effort you know the older
people living next door just call them
up and say can i help you get uh go out
and go shopping for it and so you would
have potentially
federal support of that kind of thing so
these kinds of efforts and identify
where their vulnerable people live
it's really challenging in
multi-generational homes in l.a county
for instance there's a lot of
older people living together with
younger people in relatively crowded
they're there it's really quite a
challenge but there again you can use
resources so if grandma uh
is worried that grandson has come home
but is potentially been exposed grandson
calls grandma says i've been i might
have been at a party where i might do
that where covid was grandma calls
public health public health and then
says okay you can have this hotel room
for a couple of days
until you check to turn negative in case
it wasn't clear
the idea of focused protection
is the people that are vulnerable
protect them
and everybody else goes on with their
lives open up the economy just do as it
was before and there was still fear
abroad so there still would be some
restrictions people would pose on
themselves they probably would go to
parties less the grandsons probably
wouldn't go so many parties right um uh
that there would be less
less participation in big gatherings uh
you may even save like big gatherings in
order to restrict community spread again
i'm not against any of that
but you shouldn't be closing businesses
you shouldn't be closing churches and
synagogues you shouldn't be closing you
shouldn't be forcing people to not go to
to school you should you should not be
shuttering businesses you should just
let just allow society to go on some
disease will spread but as we've seen
the lockdown didn't stop the disease
from spreading anyways
right so what do you make of the
criticism that this idea like
all good ideas
cannot actually be implemented in a
heterogeneous society where there's a
lot of people intermixing
and
once you open it up people like the the
younger people will just forget that
this is even existing and they'll stop
caring about the older people and mess
up the whole thing and the government
will not want to fund
any kind of the great efforts you're
talking about about food delivery and
then food delivery services be like why
the heck am i helping out on this anyway
because like it's not making me much
money and so therefore like all good
ideas it will collapse
that might be true i mean i think uh
it's always a risk with policy thing but
i think like think back to the moment
but we actually felt like we were in
this together to some extent yes
right i think i think that that um that
empathy that we had that was used to
like
tell people to stay in and like happily
st not ruling happily but like stay in
um to like wear a mask or to to do all
these things that we thought would help
other people
could have been redirected to actually
helping the people who most needed to be
especially i do remember
march
uh so this is even way before barrington
all that kind of stuff
march april may
there was a feeling like if we all just
work together
yeah we'll solve this right and that may
be started to when did that start
breaking down i mean the
unfortunately the election is mixed into
this yeah that it became politicized but
i think it lasted quite a long time i
think into the summer i think there was
some some of that sense
uh i don't know it obviously varied
among different people but um
but i think that it's true it would have
been challenging it's also true that
it's heterogeneous exactly the way you
said
um but what that means is you need a
local response
a response so like like my vision of a
public health officer is someone that
understands their community
not not necessarily the nation at large
but their community and then works
within their community to figure out how
to deploy the resources that have
available
um to do to do the kind of protection
policies we're talking about that's
that's what should have happened instead
they spent a huge amount of efforts
closing making sure businesses stayed
closed
businesses that
i mean there were you know like hardware
stores that closed
what good did closing a hardware store
do
for the spreader code if it had an
effect on spread covert spread i mean
it's going to be mario checking to make
sure that plexiglas was put up
everywhere which now in retrospect turns
out to probably made the disease worse
um
you know masking enforcement
so shaming around mask i mean a huge
amount of effort on things that were
only tangentially related to focus
protection what if we turned our energy
that enormous energy put into that
instead into focused protection of the
vulnerable that's essentially the
conversation i was calling for
and it wasn't i mean i didn't think of
it as we had every single idea i mean we
gave some concrete proposals
and we got but the criticism we got was
that those those concrete proposals
weren't enough
and the answer to that i have is that's
true they weren't enough i wasn't
thinking of them as enough i was
thinking that they would i wanted to
involve an enormous number of people in
local public health to help think about
how to do focused protection in their
communities
the question
that's interesting here is about the
future too
uh so uh kovit has very specific
characteristics like you mentioned about
the curve of the the the death rate
based on the like it's it's uh it seems
like with covid it's a little bit easier
to actually identify
a group of people that you need to
protect
um so other viruses may not be this way
so
might lock down be a good idea like hard
core lockdown for a future virus
that's 10 times deadlier but spreads at
the same rate as covid or maybe another
way to ask that is imagine a virus
that's 10 times deadlier what's the
right response i mean i think it's
always going to be focus protection but
the group that needs the focus
protection may change depending on the
biology of the virus right so the polio
epidemic in the 40s and 50s in the u.s
the the great the people at most risk
were children yeah
we didn't know really at the beginning
there was this vehicle oral spread
and so we did all kinds of crazy things
um
including like spreading spraying ddt in
communities
which was somehow supposed to get rid of
polio
but the focus was on whenever there was
an outbreak they would close a school
down
and that was the right thing to do
because that group that needed
protection
where it was children and those the
disease was spread we thought in schools
um
i don't think there's a single formula
that works
but there's a single principle that
works right no matter i can't it's hard
to imagine a disease that's uniformly
deadly across every group and every
single person
there's always going to be some group
that's differentially
harmed
there's always going to be some group
that's differentially protected and that
that may change over time right so like
the in the uh
in this disease
in this epidemic
as people got infected and recovered we
now had a class of people that were
pretty well protected against the
disease
they should be they would like instead
of ostracizing them because they don't
want a vaccine we should we should be
allowing them to work i mean we're
having
staffing shortages in hospitals now
because we forgot that principle
is uh
quite a bit of this a technology problem
so being able to
so some of
how much of it is this
sociological problem
uh how much of it is a technology
problem
like where do you uh put the blame
sort of on why this didn't go so great
and how it can go great in the beginning
i mean think about lockdowns like if we
didn't have zoom we wouldn't have
lockdowns right there's there's a reason
in 2009 we didn't lock down i mean we
didn't have the technology to replace
work with this remote
um with this remote technology
so we had good lockdown technology yeah
and zoom we didn't have
good focus protection technology yeah i
mean focus protection is always going to
be complicated especially for something
like this that's spread so easily it's
going to be complicated and i'm i'm very
i'm the last person to say it would have
been perfect
there's there would have been people
that would have gotten sick but they got
sick anyways the hope was that if we
suppress community spread low enough
we can protect the vulnerable that was
the hope by lockdown
the reality was that
only a certain class of people were able
to benefit from a lockdown the rest of
society we call them essential workers
had to keep working and they got sick
yeah
and the disease kept spreading it didn't
actually have a substantial effect on
community spread in the in in non
laptop class populations
and also we should probably expand the
class of people we call vulnerable to
those who would suffer
who who have the capacity to suffer
uh given the policies they're you're
weighing
it's very
disingenuous to call the vulnerable just
the people
obviously we had the very specific
meaning but broadly speaking vulnerable
should include anybody
who can suffer based on the policies you
take in response to a virus there's
something just that principle you just
said i completely agree with is is uh
something i think has been lost
uh
and unfortunately lost right so
the policies themselves
if they have harm those are real
yeah and we shouldn't pretend like
they're not
and and and essentially demonize the
people that that that suffer them
or pretend i mean like a lot of times
like the depression that we've been
talking about that's
thought of as like not as not so
important but it is important
uh it and uh
especially the the harm to the people in
poor countries it's like been out of
sight item out of mind in much of the
rich parts of the world once again i've
hoped that we
seeing this learning the lessons of
history with the communication tools we
have now will learn this it's like going
to another country and bombing targeted
terrorist locations
and there's going to be some civilians
who die pretending that that
the child who watches their dad die is
not going to grow up first of all
traumatized but second of all
potentially bring more hate to the world
than uh the hate that you were allegedly
fighting in the first place that's
another sort of
um considering only one kind of harm and
not the full range of harms that are
being caused by your policies you know
like the good return to focus protection
we we still should be following the
policy now for covet and we're not right
so the vaccines
are there's a great shortage in vaccines
you wouldn't know it in the united
states in rich parts of the world but in
there's a great shortage of vaccines
we're not going to be able to vaccinate
the um most of the like the entire set
of elderly at least and or
larger groups until late 2022.
huge numbers of
older people around the world in poor
countries
that have not had not covered recovered
yet so they're still quite vulnerable
have not had the vaccine
and yet we're talking about vaccinating
five-year-olds
yeah
who benefit
if at all from the vaccines of just a
very little bit because they face such a
low risk of harm from covet
well something that's a little bit
near and dear to our specific the two of
our hearts
so you're at stanford
so stanford recently
announced that they're going back to
virtual
at least for some period of time in
response to the esc maybe you can
clarify but i think it's in response to
the escalated um
how would they phrase it's related to
omicron
and
a few other universities are kind of
like
uh considering back and forth in my
perspective
as somebody who loves in-person lectures
who
um
sees the value of that
to students to young minds
also looking at the data
seems
the
[Music]
risk aversion
in university policies around this given
how healthy the student population is
seems
not well calibrated let's put it this
way also pathological pathological is
one way to put it given that i believe
depending on the university but i think
many universities require that the
student body is vaccinated
at this point
so
i think it's a big mistake by stanford
to do this
and um
i'd like to say that because i just hope
mit doesn't
but what are your thoughts about that is
there is
i completely agree with you i think um
we have
failed in our mission
to educate our students
by these this decision uh and i think i
frankly just more broadly i think we
failed generally over the course of the
last year and a half in living up to our
educational mission
in-person
teaching is vital
for now i can understand you have uh if
you have older faculty the the principle
of focus protection says provide some
alternative teaching arrangements for
them
that makes sense to me
from the kids point of view
they're more harmed by not getting the
education we promised them
then by then by covet
so applying this principle of this
focused protection
let young professors teach in person
this is before the vaccine after the
vaccine let everyone teach in person
yeah this this the part i don't
understand the discussion we're even
having because
um
okay let's leave focus protection aside
here because that's a brilliant policy
for perhaps for the future when there's
no vaccine now with the vaccine i'm i'm
misunderstanding something here because
we're now in a space
that's
psychological not it's no longer about
biology because
with the booster shots which i believe
mit is now requiring before january
with the booster shots the data shows no
matter how old you are the risks are
very low
for
ending up in a hospital
relative to all the other risks you face
when you're older
i don't i don't understand can you
explain the policy around
closing
a university but also just a
policy about
just being so
scared still
in the university setting i think the
universities the great university has
done great harm
by modeling this kind of behavior yes
that to me decided to keep interrupting
but to me the university should be the
beacon of great behavior not not the
beacon of like scared conservative
let's not mess up
let's not make it pathological let's not
make anybody angry
let's it should be a place to play in
the space of ideas yes
so i think
the central problem is actually related
to the central problem of covid policy
more generally
the goal seems to be
to stop the disease from spreading
rather than to reduce the harm from the
disease
if the if the goal is to stop the
disease from spreading the sad fact is
we have no technology to stop to
accomplish that
at this point yes because like uh it's
already deeply integrated into the human
civilization well i mean it's it's here
forever right there's a zero survey of
white-tailed deer in the u.s it turns
out 80 of white-tailed deer in the u.s
have coveted antibodies
dogs get it cats get it
there's almost certainly human human
animal transmission of it um
i mean presumably i mean i've heard bats
get it apparently um so so you you have
uh you have a situation where you have
this disease that's here to stay yeah
and it and the vaccines don't stop the
spread of it the lockdowns don't stop
the spreader we have no technology to
stop the spread of it
and so we're burning the earth trying to
stop do something that's impossible
rather than
working on what's possible
uh and so like you know like letting
regular college happen that's a great
good universities are a wonderful
invention and and it's contributed so
much to society to decide to shut it
down
the universities should be fighting
tooth and nail to not be shut down not
the other way around yeah
whatever the mechanisms that uh results
in the university is doing that that's
probably this is me talking it probably
has to do with certain incentives for
the administration probably has to do
with lawyers and legal kinds of things
to
to avoid uh legal trouble but once again
it's when the administration has too
much power and too much uh definition of
what the policy is for the university
that's when you get into trouble the
beauty the power of the university
should be about the faculty and the
students
administration
just gets in the way
get out of the way i mean they can help
organize things they play some important
role but they certainly do but they need
to remember what the mission is the
mission is not
safety the mission actually university
should be dangerous places you know for
ideas and and and whatnot
you